[Music]
so my name is Nadia Baron I'm a postdoc
in digital humanities and American
Studies so my project is called the
decisive Network Magnum photos in the
post or image market and it's related to
my book manuscripts which is the history
of the photo agency Magnum so something
that I was really interested in is
Magnum is really known for a couple of
its famous photographers and there are
chronic images that they produced and
what I was interested in doing is a
couple of things first
based on the archival research that I
did showcasing the labor of other staff
who helped the photographers become
famous and who helped them produce their
work so the largest view here is
dedicated to really bringing to life
people like secretaries and editors
people who work behind the scenes on
editing Magnum films and distributing
Magnum films another part of the project
that I'm interested in doing is showing
how agents sales agents sold magnums
pictures around the world so there the
idea is to have a map of the world
showing how post in after World War two
magazine markets emerged and how Magnum
was servicing those markets with us
pictures and then the third part is to
pick a couple of iconic photo stories
and to to show how they also circulated
around the world and the intervention
there is especially in the United States
we often think about photojournalism
histories as being about Life magazine
and the role the goal here is to show
that these photographers were selling to
a whole variety of markets and that they
were actually influencing global visual
culture and not just American visual
culture with the pictures they were
producing
it's been really great to collaborate
with the digital humanities lab at Yale
particularly because I found that a lot
of the pre-existing software on network
visualization sort of all looked the
same and and put you into a mold of
having to represent networks in a
particular kind of 21st century way and
what I really wanted to do was to
represent these networks and these ideas
in the style of post-war visual culture
so the designer Monica Audrey on Reed I
showed her some of the publicity
materials that Magnum was creating about
itself and so what we've done is we've
come up with she's come up with ways to
model the presentation of this
information on that mid-century visual
culture and that's really exciting to
the basis for the the project is is a
tool to to explore the testimonies of
Holocaust survivors witnesses and
bystanders from three different
collections the portion of video archive
which has as a collection of 4,500
testimonies the USC Shoah foundation and
the US Holocaust Memorial Museum
both the USC Shoah foundation and US
Holocaust Memorial Museum have
contributed over a thousand testimony
transcripts each to this project in art
collection combined with that comes to
about 3,000 testimony transcripts the
anthology is very much a project that is
similar out there sort of traditional
historical work in which a body of text
is explored and and and similar
experiences are brought together from
those texts to explore
more let's say common common experiences
that survivors may have may have met in
in the camps or prior to or in the
post-war period the anthology however
uses sophisticated data text mining
tools to to explore this very large
amount of data in order to pull those
common experiences together the other
aspect of this project is a search tool
which allows researchers and educators
to search across all of these 3,000
testimony transcripts and sophisticated
ways to locate subjects related to their
research topics so there's really two
sides to project anthology and the
search tool a fortune off video archive
and the d-h lab have started a
partnership beyond this project this is
our first effort to working together by
bringing Gabbert otha post doctoral
associate we are funding the
postdoctoral associate and the d h lab
is working together with him to produce
this project but in addition to this
we're also looking to bring in a
developer to work on additional fortune
off projects in the future
a master's student at Yale University so
I'm studying East Asian Studies and
American Studies but both of them have
an interest in the history the landscape
and trauma that takes place in the
landscape and investigating that with
digital media tools such as AutoCAD
Rhino and adobe illustrator it's
actually based off with Jeju coals novel
open city and the protagonist is julius
and julius is Nigerian doctor of
Columbia University who traverses the
city and meditates on various events
historically that have happened and one
of the main quotes of the book is that
the site is a palimpsest and a palace s
is a document where things have been
written on it and erased and rewritten
and you can find the imprint of those
things from the past in that document
and when you think about atrocity and
the development of Manhattan you like
you know wait a minute my fiancee is in
architecture student and we're using
exploded axons all the time
and what's a better documen kind of
expressor than excluded axon to show the
palimpsest of history so we picked four
to four points that k juco talked about
which was free colonial Manhattan when
it was occupied by the Algonquin Lynn
Lenape Dutch colonial man
we picked 1664 right on the cusp of when
it was sold to the British 1863 draft
riots in 2001 the 9/11 attacks and we
really wanted to express two things we
wanted to talk about the fact that he's
articulating all this information but
when you're talking about literature
you're cherry-picking pieces of
information from within a broader
archive and we wanted to compare those
two things and in order to do that we
traced out his experiences as a
programmatic axon so that really shows
these events layered on one another and
then them separated by time and at the
same time we've recreated from historic
maps these three-dimensional interactive
spaces that have box box and if you
click on them you open up the archive so
I wanted people to understand the wealth
of information that he was tapping into
and begin to actually explore these
spaces so it's telling time travel in
four distinct periods
[Music]
what I'm presenting here is a Python
module it's a software module and it's
designed for use inside of the Jupiter
or computational notebook format and the
idea is that if you're a researcher
who's working with a lot of image data
and in particular if you want to get
sort of human eyes on the data there are
some very kind of concise ways of
producing montages of images let me show
you an example of this sort of these
montages of images and they can be
sorted according to visual properties of
the images or according to like metadata
variables like place and time and and so
the idea is in particular if you're a
researcher in the humanistic sciences
and you want your human expertise to be
the primary way of apprehending these
images rather than sort of like machine
perception this enables you to get human
eyes on your images in a fairly
efficient way without having to leave
the computational notebook format one
thing I've learned in the process of
producing this software is I had to try
to strike a balance and in this case
between the kind of power of the tool
the the and what I mean by that is the
ability of the tool to do lots of
different things and then for it to be
learn about by a fairly kind of you know
sort of a new audience that's learning
it for the first time it can be a little
overwhelming if the tool has like too
many features and so you want to strike
a balance between kind of lots of
features and something being learn about
and sort of the user being able to
conceptualize it fairly easily at the
beginning and so I decided on you know
having just four or five very basic
plotting functions
and that have a number of kind of
options that you can change to adjust
features of the pots and I found that to
be a fairly good balance so there is a
lot of power in there but the tool is
organized according to a fairly fairly
simple model that I think the user can
kind of learn right away and so you know
this originally was designed for the use
case where maybe you're already coding
in Python a little bit and you know a
little bit of that stuff but I think it
could be an entry point for some people
who want to learn that but it's a little
daunting and I think that this is kind
of like a gentle entry into using Python
and the notebook format so this was a
collection of 300 or so tweets that we
took and what this is doing is reading
the tweets in chronological order and
every time it comes across one of these
key words it'll ping the bubble and so
the darker and larger the bubble the
more commonly it's seen and it's really
interesting because you can watch the
composition of what's being talked about
in the tweets as the movement is going
through and a couple of interesting
things where Calvin was initially not
something that was brought up into
tweets it was initially allowed master a
lot of slavery a lot of civil rights and
then as the movement on we see a lot of
increased attention to community to
campus to principles that kind of thing
and so this was just a really
interesting way to visualize what was
happening the evolution of the tools and
so this is the same set of tweets but
instead what's happening is here is sort
of the first tweet chronologically and
then it goes around in this direction
and what you can do is you can sort of
put your mouse over top of the words and
it'll map to where they appear in the
tweet so you can take a look at and for
example Gale it's really prominent in
the first couple of tweets and then in
the later section that's not
or students more prominent in the later
tweets than it is in the area - it's
that kind of thing there's just another
way to sort of visualize what's
happening on the tweets my name is
Jennifer Lee I am a medieval studies PhD
Canada my name is Eric Inslee and I am a
PhD student in the English department we
are presenting an Edition that was
developed during a graduate student
workshop the digital editing and the
manuscript of role workshop which we've
now hosted at several institutions yes
and it's a two-day workshop and we
invite graduate students and librarians
basically anybody study what do you
think having to go period to come to our
workshop and we train them to do xml and
TI and so over the course of the
workshop they design and implement code
for a digital edition of the role and we
are hosting that on our website right
now and we're running through our beta
version of our platform and we will have
a archive of about we have about 10
rolls right now that we've done and will
be hosting all those rolls online so
it's collaborative code so manuscript
rolls are unusual objects and so trying
to find a way to do justice to the
actual physical materiality of a
manuscript roll when most of most
most of the existing markup languages
are thinking about or codices books as
opposed to this you know strange long
object but you have to unroll and
interact with in this really interesting
way thinking about a way that our
editions can do justice to the
materiality of a manuscript is is
something that we've been really
interested in my name is Nathan Lin and
I'm an undergraduate computer science
major you know so I'm working on a
project that involves making 3d models
of some stone tablets that we have at
Yale so actually sorry in the art
gallery we have these stone reliefs from
the Northwest Palace in New Moon so
ancient Babylon and one motivation for
this project is of course in the last
couple of years Isis is presumed to have
destroyed this palace so one thing we
wanted to do is to work on creating
models of our existing tablets so that
we have some kind of preservation of
them and another aspect that I'm working
on is
is trying to provide the viewers with an
experience that they wouldn't be able to
get from just going to the Art Gallery
and looking at the tablets so here's
like my my 3d model of of the tablet and
one of the things that I was working on
is well the lighting we have right now
is really different from the lighting
back 2,000 years ago
so of course the tablets can look
different if it's lit by modern lights
versus if it's lit by what they probably
had a torch light so I've been working
on different models of illumination
using fire so so like the newer would be
able to cycle through these different
kinds of lighting and get a better idea
of what these tablets look like and one
portion that I'm currently working on
where this effect of lighting is really
gonna make a difference is I'm working
on trying to reconstruct what the
original coloring of these tablets would
look like because these tablets were all
originally painted 3,000 years ago if
you go to the art gallery the other
tablet you
that's art gallery you can actually see
like some red still on the feet of the
tablet so we're working on work talking
to art historians and conservation
there's must've a concert concert or
doors on what colors the tablet would
have looked like back then and that's
where the Lighting's really gonna make a
big difference because different colors
are gonna look really different under
different kinds of lighting because it's
most likely that the kinds of colors are
using would look very garish today under
normal lighting but under fire lighting
they'd be much more Sadu subdued and a
more aesthetically pleasing kind of
image
you
[Music]